[Musica]
[Applauso]
partiamo partiamo da questo video perché
ho letto che hai detto è stata una sorta
di terapia preparare questo questo
intervento si è stata una terapia perché
venivamo da due anni in cui eravamo
molto diciamo riferiti soltanto alla
malattia no vedevamo persone solo in
funzione di aggiustare qualcosa di rotto
o di risolvere un problema è invece
preparare il video è stato davvero
ripercorrere la nostra storia e aprirci
un po fino appunto a ad arrivare lì
salire sul palco è parlarne da da zero
quindi nessuno sapeva prima la nostra
storia a parlarne parlare a tutti e
anche il vostro intervento ha una storia
strana voi di fatto a te fatto richiesta
per partecipare si tra il pubblico in
realtà
e poi cosa è successo in realtà si come
avviene per tutti gli eventi ita ed
anche per gli eventi globali si fa
domanda di partecipazione e loro devono
decidere siano accertati e poi è partita
una mail personamente arrivata al
mattino in cui si chiedeva se il 3
partecipanti c'era qualcuno che aveva
una storia da raccontare per cui roberto
ha applicato dicendo un po lo stesso
messaggio che era un po la conclusione
del video quindi considera quello che
hai come come un dono e lavora
soprattutto sulle opportunità che un po
come dire voglio iscrivermi a una scuola
no viene a fare l'insegnante più o meno
livello era quello sentito che hanno ora
questo 2013 1013 sono passati tre anni e
mezzo più o meno cosa è successo in
questi anni è successo un mondo
beh innanzitutto prima eravamo soli
quando avete visto lì e poi se a parte
un altro mondo di persone appena abbiamo
detto noi abbiamo questo problema altre
persone con problemi simili quindi
traumi legati appunto a malattie
entrata in famiglia hanno detto beh sì
anche noi ce l'abbiamo e lo abbiamo
risolto così per cui abbiamo creato un
po un movimento oggi siamo circa 500 i
genitori che soltanto in italia hanno
manifestato di avere questo problema
quindi persone che prima non avevano una
struttura di riferimento non si potevano
scambiare informazioni fra loro e poi
l'altra cosa che è successa beh quello
che vedete avete visto voi prendere la
penna con mario è appunto attivare
quello che il meccanismo dei neuroni
specchio in realtà adesso è diventato un
protocollo è diventato un qualcosa di
reale perchè le prime trenta famiglie
hanno aderito al progetto e adesso siamo
appunto portando avanti un progetto
pilota con il cnr di riabilitazione
proprio basata sul sul meccanismo i
neuroni specchio e come sta mario mario
sta bene direi di sì c'è solo per
manifestare che sta bene
tempi
prima di salutarti e di farti tornare
alla tua famiglia dei vari progetti che
avete fatto file fight for stroke call
for brain mi vuoi raccontarci in uno in
particolare vuoi dirci cosa state
lavorando adesso adesso appunto stiamo
lavorando a mirrorball quindi il rendere
concreta una possibilità di
riabilitazione per persone che hanno
avuto un impairment un problema di tipo
motorio soprattutto agli arti superiori
quindi in questo senso mirò la bolla è
una piattaforma di riabilitazione che
espone i bambini a dei video costruiti
secondo particolari accorgimenti e poi
permette loro di riabilitarsi quindi di
mettere in pratica l'esercizio che hanno
imparato nel primo caso erano degli
esercizi magia insegnati loro dal dal
mago walter rolfo gli permette a quel
punto di connettersi con un altro
bambino e metterlo in pratica fra pari
quindi diciamo che la più grande
soddisfazione di questi giorni perché il
pilota è partito proprio adesso a
dicembre vedere che quello che era un
social stigma un problema un qualcosa di
cui vergognarsi è diventato un modo di
essere orgogliosi questi bambini ne sono
orgogliosi di invitare persone a casa a
far vedere come fanno i giochi magia
senti e poi ti lascia davvero andare
quando succede una cosa del genere
immagino che la propria vita si resetti
no cioè di fatto tutto diventa meno
importante però immagino anche che ci
sia una forma di sconforto di paura
profondissima lo racconta roberto nel
video qual è stata la scintilla che vi
ha fatto dire non stiamo qua giù e
cerchiamo di rialzarsi è successo
qualcosa vi siete detti qualcosa ma
probabilmente è stato qualcosa che noi
adesso razionalmente auguriamo a quel
momento lì è stata l'esperienza di dire
a un certo punto ma non vediamo
risultati della terapia tradizionale
quindi prendiamoci un momento di
distacco di evasione per noi stato
riprendere a fare la vita di prima
quindi abbiamo detto ricominciamo
viaggiare sentire musica e propria linea
di questi viaggi ci siamo resi conto che
chi mario migliorava quindi ha iniziato
a camminare proprio nei momenti però un
viaggio una situazione di di evasione
quindi probabilmente ogni tanto
resettare godendosi un po il di più il
quotidiano e non pensando invece alla g
ha aiutato a testa grazie ancora
francesca pedroni roberto d'angelo
grazie complimenti davvero
[Applauso]